- [Narrator] Let's say
you're a cheese producer,
and you need a loan because
you want to buy a tractor
or food for your cows or
really just about anything.
There's a bank in Italy
that will take your cheese
and give you cash.
This is the story of three men
and millions of dollars worth of cheese.
(light soft music)
Meet Mauro.
(speaking in a foreign language)
He's a cheese producer in
the Emiliano region of Italy.
He produces Parmigiano-Reggiano,
the so called “King of Cheese.”
(speaking in a foreign language)
(record scratching)
20,000 wheels? Holy cow,
that's a lot of cheese.
When Mauro or another cheese producer
in this part of Italy needs a loan,
they go to Credito Emiliano,
a big Italian bank.
And like any bank,
Credito Emiliano needs
collateral for their loan.
(speaking in a foreign language)
And to do that, he talks to Fausto.
He works for Credito Emiliano.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Parmigiano-Reggiano is
a special kind of cheese
because it needs to be
aged for 18 to 36 months
and a wheel can be worth
thousands of dollars.
Making it a safe long term
investment for the bank.
(speaking in a foreign language)
To be clear, the bank doesn't
store the valuable cheese
in its vaults next to gold
bars and stacks of cash.
They have a special cheese
warehouse down the road
filled with thousands and
thousands of wheels of cheese.
That's where Roberto comes in.
He's the general director of the
Tagliate General Warehouses.
That's where Credito
Emiliano stores their cheese.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Roberto and his team
take care of more than
300,000 wheels of cheese
that's currently worth more
than 160 million euros.
Without proper care, the cheese
could lose it's value.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Well Roberto, sounds to
me like the cow, the bank
and the cheese are in good hands.
(light soft music)